Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, on a une question de Karolina,
qu'on va aller écouter d'ailleurs :
« Pourquoi les Inuits aiment
prendre la peau des animaux ? »
Alors Karolina,
pourquoi est-ce que les Inuits,
et pas seulement les Inuits, mais je pense beaucoup
de Premières Nations, utilisent la peau des animaux?
C'est qu'autrefois,
avant l'arrivée des Européens,
la majorité de nos vêtements venait
justement de la peau des animaux.
On n'avait pas de coton ou de laine,
comme les Européens avaient.
Donc, la tradition qu'on avait, c'était vraiment lié
à utiliser l'animal. On mangeait la viande,
on a utilisé les os pour faire des outils
et la peau, et la fourrure, pour se garder au chaud.
C'est certain que beaucoup de gens,
maintenant, n'utilisent plus du tout
la fourrure ou le cuir, mais les Premières Nations
continuent justement
cette pratique parce qu'on est encore
sur les mêmes territoires et ce sont
les vêtements qui sont souvent les plus efficaces
et les plus résistants
pour nous tenir au chaud
dans des températures très froides.
On a des vêtements synthétiques
aujourd'hui, mais ces vêtements-là,
eux aussi, contribuent à la pollution
et aux changements climatiques.
Donc, souvent c'est de continuer avec des pratiques
traditionnelles qui étaient de respecter
l'animal. Et l'animal, lui-même,
on considérait qu'il se donnait à nous,
que si on n'avait pas été respectueux,
qu'on avait gaspillé, qu'on n'avait pas bien fait,
l'animal refusait de se faire chasser.
Donc, c'était extrêmement important
que quand on chassait l'animal, tout soit utilisé.
Et encore aujourd'hui, ce respect-là
est la première valeur qui est mise
de l'avant pour les chasseurs inuits
et des Premières Nations.
C'est certain qu'on a beaucoup de difficulté,
encore aujourd'hui,
parce qu'avec les changements climatiques
ça fait beaucoup plus de tort
aux animaux que la chasse traditionnelle
des Premières Nations. Et ça, c'est quelque
chose qu'on va combattre justement
pourrait aider l'animal et pour
lui montrer le respect, puisqu'il nous aide
à survivre sur le territoire depuis
des milliers d'années.
Alors, je suis contente, Karolina,
que toi aussi tu as à coeur la vie
et la survie des animaux sur notre territoire.
Je vous souhaite une belle semaine,
j'espère que vous allez partager la question de Karolina
et j'espère aussi que vous allez nous
envoyer encore des questions à Parole autochtone.